Hey guys! Kevin the backyard scientist here today
and today we're going to be cooking with science (or at least trying to) I mean it's perfect timing because we just got all of this food from
Blue Apron (this video is actually sponsored by Blue apron) and Sandra
and I are gonna have a contest to see who can cook the food the best.
[Sandra] I'm gonna win.
[Kevin] She thinks she is. I'm gonna try (it's probably not going to be that great) but we're going to try anyway.
And we're each going to choose a meal and cook it, so you ready? [Sandra]Ready. [Kevin] All right. Let's do it.
Let's get started, and I forgot, I don't actually know what I'm cooking right now, so Sandra, what am I going to be cooking?
[No response] This
Shrimp and Fresh, how do you say it?
[Sandra] Gnocchi. [Kevin] gno- gno- gna-  *gnocchi*. Nah, I don't think so. But, I don't know what it is,
hopefully I didn't say its wrong. Now let's actually get started
Okay, step 1, prepare the ingredients, done. Step 2, blister the tomatoes. Right here, blister the tomatoes.
And I think that I have the perfect tool for that.
This right here is a carbon arc light. It's powered by a welder that puts out about 23 volts at 80 amps,
and that's 1800 watts of power that are going through these two carbon electrodes right here. Now these things are
adjustable so I can get it just in the right focal length of this parabolic dish which is actually just a lampshade that I got
at Goodwill , it does the job really good though. Let's try it out. So this is a normal flashlight
It's about 300 lumens, and you can kinda see it flashing around here now. Let's check out the arc light
Flash light. Dude this thing is crazy!
Let me demonstrate this power by aiming at a piece of cardboard and yeah a large portion of this light given off by this is
ultraviolet light so
Yeah
Okay
Now let's try it on the tomatoes
I've got the arc lamp precariously perched right here, and I think it's time to blister these tomatoes
This is about the focal point right there...
Let's see
Yep, I'd say that those have been blistered
[Sandra]So what's next on the list.. corn? [The genius of inventions]Yep corn.
So this is going to be a fun one I get to use one of my old inventions to try to cook this corn
So lets get to the garage and I'll show you
So the instructions say "Put the corn in the oven for
30 minutes at 300 degrees" now if I put it in my kiln that's at
1500 Degrees
It should only take six minutes. No problem right. For our next test. We're going to be playing with some electricity
Actually playing is probably a bad word
We're going to be experimenting with electricity
So the distance is an electric arc can travel and jump through air is pretty much determined by the voltage of the electricity
So here let's say this neon sign Transformer is twelve Thousand Volts
The Earth can pretty much jump about a centimeter now if it was 20,000 volts it could jump two centimeters thirty thousand volts three centimeters
And so on you get the idea
Basically that means that air is acting like an insulator it prevents the electrons from going where they want to go
So say we try electricity in a vacuum?
And that should create a longer Arc because there's not enough air to get in a way of the electrons. Let's try it. Alright.
turning on the vacuum
And let's connect the electricity
Now you'll see but there's still a lot of air in there
And it's not going to create an ARC until most of the air is evacuated
Boom. Now we have electricity going
I'm Switching out the neon sign Transformer with something a little bit more powerful this right here is a microwave oven transformer.
We got the Shrimp's in here. Let me turn on the vacuum
And now let's see some plasma. Cook shrimps cook!
Now that's how you cook some shrimp right there
Well I don't think that this experiment cooked the shrimp as much as I hoped it would but I think the next experiment should be able to redeem us
Hey, how's the beams going? Going good! How's the corn going?
Uh...
It's going good.
Oh jeez
Oh wow that's hot
Okay... uh
Okay, I'm just going to look that cool down a bit. Let's try the next one.
Today we're going to be preparing our garlic and spices using manganese heptoxide
Now that is a very interesting chemical one of my favorites because it sets everything it touches on fire
I think you can understand why that's one of my favorite chemicals
It's just two simple ingredients sulfuric acid that's concentrated like 98% and then potassium permanganate
Sulfuric acid and let's just add a little bit there. Just a splash and let's mix in a little bit of this.
Oo that's a lot
Okay to demonstrate how crazy this stuff is let me put in a little bit of paper towel
And you'll see it instantly catch on fire
Okay, so the recipe also calls for some crushed red pepper flake. Let's try those out
Okay, now let's try a little bit of garlic
Aw It's just too bad I guess this garlic isn't going to make it into the dinner
Well the corn is all dry now. So let's open it up and see what it looks like
I don't know guys
Ha! Haha!
Here is the corn look at that
Totally carbonized right now. I just turn the corn into a lump of charcoal. Let's see how much it weighs right now
so the corn weighs
23-24 grams.. not even an ounce and that's funny because at first the corn weighed almost a pound before
I carbonized it so I should just be able to set the corn on fire
See that?
That is corn on the cob charcoal right there. You could cook some corn on the cob using this
Well I think that the meal is complete so let's go inside and compare to Sandra's meal and see how we did
Ok. So this is what it's supposed to look like according to the menu card with all the ingredients that looks pretty good
Let's see what I got
How do you like that?
Why is your food on fire? Well instead of cooking the pasta? I thought I could just soak it in alcohol
Set it on fire and that it would
ugh ... cook
in front of us you know like a romantic candlelit dinner. So this is a contest. We have to you know test each other's food
So you can test my food I'll test your food. This looks delicious. Let's see who wins ok?
Uhh let's not.
Oh come on. Where's the sport now?
Oh my God.
Uh..
That'll be done.
But really guys I got to give a thank-you shout-out to blue apron Foods for donating all that food for scientific purposes
blue apron is a recipe and delivery service that helps chefs with all levels cook incredible meals at home trust me
I can use all the help I can get blue apron takes care of the menu planning and shopping giving you more time to work
In the garage so all you have to do is wash the grime off your  projects and enjoy
Or just wash the grime off your hands
So there's two types of plans you can get which is just a two person family plan which is perfect for my girlfriend
Sandra and I and then there's the more advanced family plan which is for the whole family and I think that that is perfect if
You have a dog because she will try to eat
Anything you make so might as well get her her own food because she's going to try to steal some of yours nice try
All blue apron boxes are delivered in a refrigerated package
So the ingredients will stay fresh even if you're not home or too busy working on tesla coils to answer the door
More importantly blue apron has a special offer for those who support my channel the first 100 people to place a blue apron order get
Three free meals so check the link down below in the description to learn more and get your three free meals today, all right
Backyard scientist, I'll see you next time Sandra I know Every time
See you guys next time
you are so lame  I like cool I liked it. See you next time. Bye